records in the state of Virginia here he
goes
and he's putting on the handle
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
crap CJ going to shaking one good job
man
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen we have witnessed a
star being born tonight let's stop it a
star has been born tonight a star a star
like an NBA star an NBA star has been
born tonight his name will be realm
throughout over here in the thirds bro
congrats under windmak uh what were some
of your who are some of your dunk Idols
growing up what were some of your
favorite dunks in the NBA contest
growing up yeah I mean I loved Vince
Carter and uh
just watching uh the Adam uh the sorry
the Zach Levine and the Aaron Gordon
Dunk Contest was just uh it was
something I enjoyed so much and you know
I was like man if I get to be a part of
this one day you know I hope to make an
impact like those guys and you know got
a lot of inspiration from them he
incurred an injury dealing with weights
in the weight room so he stitched up in
the left hand doing all this
[Applause]
it's over ladies and gentlemen
happens
[Applause]
judges are coming over the table to
congratulate Vince Carter this is
unheard of oh my goodness gracious it is
over did I call it Daddy or what hey
Tracy McGrady he doesn't even know what
to do he's walking away he plays with
this guy every day and he's in awe
[Applause]
another look
hey Danny hey Kenny he's got three of
your top five all the time already but
what he told me before before the
contest he said he watched all of these
dunk contests he's going to take a
little bit of someone else a little bit
of Dominique and put him together so he
put the Isaiah writer with this [__]
well and threw it the bounce pass and
throw it to himself in Duncan impossible
seven inch Circle lead for Vince Carter
with a spectacular show on this first
round let's go to Cheryl